aujourd'hui je vous emmène dans le sud
sauvage à la petite-île chez madame
marie jeanne et eve femmes d'apiculteurs
qui collabore aux côtés de son mari au
développement de leur entreprise
familiale des rochers à la miellerie de
la mise en pot à la fabrication d'objets
en cire marie-jeanne nous fait partager
sa passion pour le miel et les abeilles
c'est grâce à monsieur c'est que j'ai eu
cet amour pour la sir pour le miel aussi
c'est au début c'était pas fassiez le
moment j'avais peu les abeilles je
savais même pas comment ce que mon nez
serait le miel ce n'est même pas mettre
la mise en pot c'est lui avec sa passion
avec son amour pour les à bec m'a donné
cette envie de foncer par exemple
choisir les peaux les étiquettes
il me donne cette envie de partir plus
loin un même avec les bougies
jeudi le coulage envie d'avoir deux
trois mots le dit vas-y prend puis l'a6
est vraiment c'est grâce à lui que
aujourd'hui je peux arriver à faire
quelque chose de mes dix doigts
c'est une passion que vous vivez à 2 à 2
à tous une passion convient a dû du
moment qu'il a des contraintes aussi
dans l'apiculture moi aussi j'en ai un
peu ce que vous
on vit que de ça aussi la récolte se
fait à quel moment comme la en ce moment
c'est la récole de baies roses indicible
jamais à partir cette semaine
mi mars on commencerait col de baies
roses d'accord et béro ça veut dire
qu'il ya 3 il ya trois no pour un miel a
new génération d'aujourd'hui on dit b
rose est la génération de de ma mère par
exemple on dit le faux poivrier et la
génération des arrière grands mères ont
dit lançant un il ya des gens
connaissent le miel lançant le mes soit
le miel faut parier soit le des roses
il ya trois no format miel après l'abbé
après les bernoises ont préparé le
rucher ce polar écoles de letchis quand
c'est la saison des fleurs d'élections
mais les ruches voilà ont fait l'amitié
quand les chiites ont fini en prépa
encore le rocher pour la saison de miel
de forêt et 1 6 juillet à trois variétés
de miel dans une année si vous ne venez
pas pour la récolte que en principe vous
dites que c'est un travail masculin mais
aussi c'est parce qu'on a peur de se
faire piquer par les on a peur de se
faire piquer un bon personnellement moi
bon ben si je me fais pitié je gonfle
j'ai la figure un peu transformé un bon
je laisse ça le travail pour monsieur
voilà je vois que vous vous couvrez
uniquement votre visage et non pas vos
bras est-ce que les abeilles préfère
appliquer à des endroits bien précis la
figure donc c'est mieux de se protéger
au niveau du visage et vise à aller à ce
moment là on risque rien voilà oui ou
pas grand chose oui il ya combien de
cadres à l'intérieur de cette non la
preuve la première heure c'est à dire on
met d'icade
d'accord il est bien dans cette note
qu'à voir guy câbles 9,9 cad
c'est à dire plus les cadets sont son on
et dwan vraiment est à pourvoir dès
câbles de miel à ces personnes
il ya que du miel c'est assez épais le
cade donc si on mettait d'icade c'était
plus masquer sa vie cap donc d'accord
quant lui parle dans son rocher moi je
reste à la maison
soit je reçois les clients qui viennent
visiter la niaiserie
j'ai les enfants aussi j'ai le repas
aussi à préparer pollue parce que de
partir dans un rocher depuis le matin 6h
du matin il rentre à 11 heures il ne
leur pas d'être fait un bond et je
préfère mon c'est pour ça je viens pas
souvent
mais quand c'est le thé à pisé
reconnaîtra le regarde où les danseurs
danseuses amène à l'iss jusqu'à terre
tout arrive d'en découdre et candidat
dans des caisses on appelle ça des
cadres des câbles
ça arrive mais là on passe bas coût des
véhicules et moi c'est seulement quand
il lui arrive je joue je prends 1 kg
d'aisé pécule on enlève c'est les
opercules on enlève ou bien enlevé à
enlever vous l'ajoutez pas vous l'a
récupéré en jeu récupère la cia pour
fêter mes objets la sortie du bac
désoperculer des cadres sont ensuite mis
dans la machine à extraction ou en
quelques minutes il se vide de
l'essentiel de leur noël
l'étape suivante consiste en une
filtration supplémentaires pendant
quelques jours avant la mise en pot mais
c'est toujours la mise en pot manuela
manu ya pas deux est créé à ces mois là
c'est beaucoup voilà
je n'ai rien demandé
on s'arrête le midi bon j'ai lâché
récupérer des barques désoperculer
constitue depuis trois ans que marie
jeanne la matière première pour la
fabrication de ces objets une activité
nouvelle qu'elle a accepté de nous faire
découvrir quand la cia et déjà reposer
un parce qu'on récupère encore un peu de
miel
ces fonds de l'acier et j'ai récupéré
comme ça enfin déjà filtré dans ça prend
pour une heure une heure deux heures une
heure et c'est beau c'est bon et moment
au moment que j'ai besoin bon je prends
mes pains pour faire bouger le moment
bon ça c'est stockés dans un coin
s'abîme pas ça vieillit mais ça prend
une heure aussi parce que je vous donne
un exemple à la sueur du jeune au bout
quelques temps bout d'un an deux ans et
devient plus ma roue mais là comme au
mans j'ai besoin bon je fais fondre à
mon pain de si ça se passe
directement dans une marmite et là je
commence
on va faire la filtration avec une
petite casserole et amis
tant qu'on fait attention ce que c'est
très chaud
voilà là la cire et les trop chaude pour
attendre qu'elle se refroidissent un
petit peu pour vider leur le bois comme
ça ça court
bonjour
je
là ça prend une heure il n'ya en 3d ça
dépend si la ciel et bien refroidi bon
bain comme la l'aprue plus une fière
parce qu'elle en quoi un petit peu d'eau
chaude
l'ag des moules le moment je dois faire
le montage de la mèche
voilà
je suis
brown
mais quand
ma
moi je dirais pas ma culture maya
apiculteurs essayer de foncer avec le
mark nous d'animaux c'est ça c'est la
passion entre en coupe puis la fra
monsieur ça vient petit à petit